[Music]
Destinee - is only days away and as the
sequel to one of the most successful new
IPs ever it brings its fair share of
pressure to developer Bungie it's a
chance to not only expand on the success
of the first destiny but also to show
that Bungie is willing to adapt and
evolve as fan expectations morph with
each passing month to put it bluntly
destiny - is bungees chance to prove
that the studio can still set new bars
because that's exactly what Bungie has
done it laid the foundations for things
we take for granted today freedom of
movement and first-person shooters and
multiplayer matchmaking in console games
we also might not be waiting for the
Xbox 1x to release if halo hadn't made
the case for Microsoft's Console push 16
years ago and say what you will about
destiny but it has found an audience to
say the least
like planetside or warframe its world
blends first-person shooter elements
with those often consigned to mmo's
Ubisoft chase that formula with the
division and emerged with greater
initial sales than even destiny and then
Bioware the iconic studio lauded for its
story driven rpgs seems to be chasing
the MMO shooter genre with its upcoming
project anthem so given bungees ongoing
impact now seems as good a time as any
to look back at how its games change
things and to remember some of its
greatest triumphs that often go
overlooked today
[Music]
the story of bungees founding has been
told before dozens of times by hundreds
of different people they all paint the
picture of a ragtag group of irreverent
college grads always looking for new
ways to do things although they're
arguably best known for their work on
the Xbox Bungie founders Alex Seropian
and Jason Jones began their work on the
niche Macintosh platform they created
early games such as the top-down shooter
Operation Desert Storm and the RPG
Minotaur the labyrinths of Crete
soon after they realized the value of 3d
graphics and set to work on a port for
Minotaur however the game didn't
translate well into the new perspective
and Bungie pivoted in 1993 it made
pathways into darkness the first-person
shooter that established the company is
a legitimate player in the burgeoning
world of game development from this
point forward Bungie was agile finding
success with its ability to adapt
difficult circumstances with juggernaut
such as doom and System Shock on PC
Bungie released marathon the first in a
trilogy of shooters that would give
Macintosh players their own first-person
tentpole and while it didn't find as big
of an audience as its counterparts
marathon did help establish one of the
genres most important mechanics we take
free look for granted today in most
shooters but when marathon released the
ability to completely control your view
with a mouse was novel in the original
doom you could only move your view from
side to side in 1994 System Shock you
had to toggle into Mouse look others
consigned your aiming controls entirely
to the keyboard marathons freedom of
movement popularized a level of
verticality that's the default now and
some of the best multiplayer map design
makes good use of it games such as
counter-strike overwatch and the
original quake are legends largely
because of marathons precedent
despite marathons oft overlooked
importance it didn't find the audience
Bungie would amass with its later titles
but it's sold well enough for the studio
to continue experimenting it expanded
into the PC market it created myth a
strategy title that garnered a cult
community and Oni a third-person action
game that would later be ported by
Rockstar Games but as the 90s came to a
close Bungie began work on another
project it was said to be a real-time
strategy game similar to bungees earlier
myth but set in a sci-fi universe
however the team decided against this
opting instead to
make a third person shooter using a
similar futuristic setting but Bungie
turned on a dime yet again creating
something completely different than the
original plan
[Music]
helos impact on the world of video games
is pervasive
it's almost omnipresent so much so that
we often forget how much the series
really has changed things throughout its
lifespan for one thing I don't think we
would be nearing the release of the Xbox
1x if it weren't for a halo combat
Evolved the original Xbox may have gone
extinct
along with Microsoft's efforts to push
into the console market at the time if
Bungie hadn't signed the deal to bring
its shooter to the new platform halo
made the Xbox a contender in the console
space and laid the seeds that would make
Microsoft a powerhouse in the gaming
world
in a similar vein Xbox Live might not be
the staple it is today if halo 2 hadn't
become a multiplayer phenomenon when it
released setting the standards for fluid
matchmaking and helping game such as
quake 3 arena to push console online
multiplayer
[Music]
I could go into the countless
innovations Halo introduced to the
shooter genre throughout the years but I
don't have that kind of time here but I
will say that Halo games since the start
have also just been fun and it's
difficult to pinpoint why maybe it's the
way each weapon has a different feeling
or maybe it's the way various enemy
types affect the ebb and flow of combat
or maybe it's the way it uses open
environments to create chaotic battles
but also cramped corridors to introduce
a terrifying foes the moment-to-moment
gameplay is always hard to describe but
I think that's what makes it so good
Longy spent a ridiculous amount of time
making you forget there was a controller
in your hand countless games have
borrowed from halos many iterations
trying to mimic the flow of its
mechanics and pacing of its firefights
to this day there are few shooters I
could point to that have succeeded
though the new doom titanfall 2 and of
course destiny come to mind but more on
that shortly all this is to say that
halo was sort of a miracle it was almost
a real-time strategy game it was almost
a third-person shooter but Bungie made
it work as something else entirely and
it was so good that it legitimized the
Xbox and later Xbox Live and console
online multiplayer across the board
after Halo Reach bungees farewell to the
legendary series it was hard to imagine
where it might go next like many people
I have a complicated relationship with
destiny there are times when I love it
there are times when I hate it I'll call
it boring one day only to finish a
harrowing nightfall strike with friends
than next I don't always feel as if
destiny is respecting my time and yes I
think it can be exploitative in the ways
it's random loot system works back when
he was a GameSpot Danny O'Dwyer did an
episode of the point that I still watch
sometimes comparing vanilla destiny to a
slot machine where you have no control
over your own rewards but regardless I'm
excited for destiny - it sounds like
Bungie knows what it needs to do to make
the series the juggernaut of
hyper-connected fun that it could be and
I'm cautiously optimistic that it'll
pull it off or at least get a little bit
closer because make no mistake destiny
is a phenomenon before the division
usurped it destiny was the most
successful new IP ever selling over 500
million dollars on its first day it took
the pitch-perfect feel of bungees halo
games and place them in an MMO it
connected hundreds of thousands of
players in cooperative strikes six
player raids and a share
social space destiny wasn't the first
game to do this but much like halo
established consoles as a viable
platform for PC quality shooters destiny
makes the strongest case for MMO design
and shooters I'm not sure what Bungie
will do after destiny - if it ever does
decide to leave it behind but throughout
its history Bungie has proven that it
knows how to adapt it knows how to
change and in doing so the studio has
flourished it's one of the few
developers that can claim to have had a
massive impact on video games in general
it found ways to go against the current
without sacrificing quality in the
process we may not always recognize it
right away but bungees influences
everywhere it's just a matter of looking
in the right places
[Music]
hey everyone thanks so much for watching
episode 13 of reboot it's a long time
halo fan I had a lot of fun making this
one and as always we want your input so
in the meantime before our next episode
get your questions in what you think of
this episode are you excited for destiny
too you can hit us up on twitter at
jacob deck or emma hardy and as always
leave a thought in the comments below
and we might feature it on our next
episode we'll see you then
[Music]
you